sunday star-studded show will be katy
perry's first performance
since baby daisy we'll also see bieber
sing and the weeknd
but host taraji p henson is excited to
see
this mama yeah yeah jennifer lopez
at maluma i can't wait to see that it's
gonna be a big show
there's a little bit of breaking news
one of the crew members tested positive
for covid
will that affect anything in any way oh
no not at all
everybody's been tested i've tested
every day this week
[Music]
how is everything going because last
time we talked you were
struggling a little bit but dealing with
the pandemic what's going on
with the wedding planning it's a mess
yeah i'm
i'm cool now i'm much better just put it
that way
last month taraji announced she called
off her wedding and split with her
fiance of two years
kelvin hayden it was right after
she went on a much-needed 50th birthday
girls trip to mexico
i felt myself slipping and so i was like
you know what i'm not going to do is let
50
happen to me get control of this mental
and not be like you getting oh don't
nobody care you know you ain't working
well
no one's working it's coping
so i felt that coming and then i called
my trainer and i was like let's make it
happen
not that bad you'll get down here i
don't have those low lows anymore
so anybody out there that might be going
through
this darkness like literally working out
with you when you hear that
it really works and don't worry you
don't look a day
over 30 you're going you don't either
whatever your face cream is honey send
some to me
[Music]